Oh, Reflame, it's time.
It's that time again when all your tingles are belong to us.
Good morning, Little Reflame.
Good evening, Little Reflame.
Good afternoon, Little Reflame.
A little fairy told me you've not been tingling recently.
Well, obviously, there's only one solution that's viable, huh?
And that's to get a Scottish lass to tingle, yeah?
So, I have my assortment of tools that's gonna help me try and tingle you. Does that sound like a deal?
Are you still not tingling? You're a stubborn one, you know that, Reflame.
But don't think that's the end of my arsenal, okay?
I'm only just getting started with you.
Oh dear Reflame, thou art tingles, worry not, for I will be your consort.
What?
Do you want me to say trigger words?
Are you susceptible to that Fiona?
Purple, burglar, lar, purple, burglar, lar, purple, burglar, lar.
That's what you wanted, to be honest.
I want to, yeah, I want to want to, yeah.
Well, you're so tingling today by late when you're a challenge, okay?
Is it weird when I like that in your eyes when I do this?
Do you like...
Beauty is Mars, it's absolutely desperate to make you tingle.
Oh, oh, oh, I'm running out of tingles, help.
Why?
Like, like, like a lollipop.
I feel like my accent is weird, like it's like a lollipop.
And we need to have no stream like this.
I mean, she...
When you want to tingle for me, don't you, Reflame?
You can feel that pleasure take over.
I've not even dreamed you yet, I haven't conditioned you yet.
And you can't help, feel.
Feel sensitive to my teasing.
You've done it before, you've been hypnotized by others.
Good, because that means this cold fish can come right along and steal you for herself.
I do love a pre-trained Reflame.
I mean, not this kind of hypnosis.
What?
Oh, I pressed the wrong one, you didn't see that?
Come on.
If you want a real hypnosis ASMR about making a deal,
I will do hours of being under with me live,
but you have to give me time to make you okay.
What?
Is the microphone loud enough?
I think it is.
Do hours of being under, or if you're difficult,
do hours of reassurance that your ass is going under?
Little Reflame, you need to rest, don't you?
So don't fade it.
I hate when you fade.
You know I like when you're easy for me.
Don't you like it when you're my easy boy?
Are you squidding me right now?
Deal.
Oops, deal.
Thank you real good for today.
I'm Brian, for showing up with you.
Can you fit the microphone in the microwave earlier again?
If the microwave meets my ass.
Okay, I have an iron glove in your cleaning tool.
I'm like picking on your little soap on here.
It's just a fucking thing.
Brian jumpscare.
Okay, let me make sure that you're checked out,
or at least we can go ahead.
Easy brain, yeah.
I like when you guys are easy brain,
because physically I'm weaker and you're stronger,
but I want you to be easy, which is why I use hypnosis.
Did you not think it was suspicious
whenever I called the readings the R word?
It's not happening consciously, don't know.
Hi.
Come here, little replay.
Fall to the deep trust.
Fall and never look back.
What are you drinking?
Is it not your ink?
I guess it must be honey tea instead then.
My little replay.
Did you like the Thai ASMR?
I uploaded some Thai ASMR,
and I had to take my clothes off at the start.
Oops.
Are you wanting me to say any trigger words?
Wait, I'm sure I know how to sign this up.
I'm a big girl.
One second, I'm going to say up-trigger words.
So you guys can anonymously ask me what to say, okay?
Damn.
Okay.
I would like...
...
That's not how you spell that word.
Okay, can someone send me something to taste that?
Yeah.
Okay, perish, okay.
You can say trigger words and stuff.
If you type one word, I assume that's a trigger word.
Someone says tentacle.
Tentacle.
Caramel.
My dumb little replay.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Oh no.
I thought I turned that down.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry I thought I fucking turned that down, Brian.
God damn it, Brian.
Sorry, I turned it down.
Thank you, Anonymous.
Tingle us.
Tingle us off the dream.
Sorry, I will apologize with kisses.
Wins the cup.
You like the word wins the cup?
Corp.
go go go
go go
sh sh sh sh
you wanna hug?
okay, instead of a hug I'll put you in between my thighs
enjoy
oh wait, did I do it right?
or does it sound different again?
oh no, I can't see your ears
I can do this
put your hand between my thighs right now
put my hands are free
go go go
this is my weakness
all your dangles are belong to us
sh sh sh
wow
someone likes the trigger word
bonk, like b-wank
bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk
bonk
bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk
so I want to
disc-er, disc-er
disc disc disc disc
disc disc disc disc disc
disc disc
disc
Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, Ska, S
Pickle, pickle, pickle, pickle, pickle, pickle, pickle
bear walkie
did you know, stroney, that you're a good girl?
but yeah, i'm a good girl
now you're gonna reward me for it, or are you just gonna stand there calling me a good girl?
do something about it, reflin
location
loooocation
looocation
looooooo canción
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay
loco ko loco ko, loco ko
Oh! My name doesn't make very good ASMR it's just Про cooled
it's just cause uuuhhh spending uuuuuhhhh
If you're gonna call me a good girl, you better know what to do when you put me in subspace.
If you're just gonna stand there looking like a fill of wiefling, just saying good girl
over and over again, then you don't deserve what comes after.
In fact, you probably deserve punishment for such a deed towards me.
So think next time.
Think long and hard about what you wanna do to me.
Someone wants fissi. Fissi isn't a good trigger word in my accent.
Fissi. Fissi.
Tom Losloss, get fucked. Oh, I should get that commissioned.
You just want kisses, okay?
Okay, good girl, okay, good girl, okay, good girl.
Good, good, good, good, good, good, good.
Would you be able to put a vibranord right near the mic?
Uh, I think no.
Someone wants Loch Nams. Or do you want the Scottish way where you just log?
What is Loch Nams?
Loch Nams.
Okay, I think that was the quote. Thank you, anonymous.
Anonymous says, good girl, I'm starting to think you don't know what you did, Rieflin.
Unironically, don't lose, lose.
You're going nowhere with this buddy.
Mommy's ready and prepared for everything.
So you might as well just sit down, like the good boy you are, and take it.
Do you understand?
Say yes, mommy.
Oh, it's one of those days, Rieflin.
Can't break me.
Thank you for trying to give mommy your tip, but it didn't work.
Oh, you're such a good boy, Rieflin.
Can you say, omelette de fromage?
Oui.
Bonjour, je m'appelle Astronique Delce.
J'ai joué au S-M-R, bienveillue, et j'ai emmené tout format pour un petit déjeuner.
Of course, French Astronique can hurt you.
Oh, earplug.
Your French sounds very cute.
Ah, merci beaucoup.
For some reason, my voice goes later when I speak French. It is a mystery.
Je suis mignon, non.
Son est-ce que ça hoque toi?
I can spell on you.
Oh.
I welcome your French hypnotic call-fish overlord.
Can we have color-borne tapping? Of course, little Rieflin.
Let me get my tattoo. I don't know if you can hear.
That's my color-borne.
I don't know how easy it is to hear, though.
Mignon, mignoné, mignoné.
Merde.
Petit boueux français, désolé.
With a cloud cover.
A Rieflin cover.
Oh, but for being a good girl, I bend you against the wall and give you kisses so curious in your eyes.
Good Rieflin. That's how you gain dominance.
Hey.
Oh, mommy and the latest audio which your head be facing, whatever head be facing away or towards,
so I implied that you're facing towards me when I stop talking.
Yeah.
Mommy, can you say done with the high table?
Rieflin, my darling, my favorite child.
I have one thing to say to you.
Done with the high table.
Rieflin.
My smart and wise Rieflin.
Where's my little ear cleaner?
Ecco. You like the word ecco.
Ecco, ecco, ecco.
Let me just clean the inside.
I think I might have a better tail for cleaning that side of your ear, Rieflin.
Let me try.
That was my throat.
Rieflin.
You like all good to me.
Maybe please receive the intimate gift of ear from your lungs.
Oh, you want hot?
Can you feel my hot breath against your rieflin?
Just imagine your mind and your business at your PC like you normally are.
And you hear me walk in, but you don't think much of it because you're so distracted.
And then just to make sure you know I'm there, I breathe my whole breath on your ear.
And you giggle because you know it's me.
And you feel my arms go onto your shoulders to try and relax you a little bit.
Oh, my briefings so dense.
You need something to help relieve him.
What could I possibly do?
Oh, baby boy.
I'll let your mind do the rest, shall I?
I need some time to bust a nutty rainbow.
This one goes so deep.
Trying to lure me into a false and insecure rieflin.
Don't you not want to fall?
Don't you not want to see what fun and intense things I'll get up to with you?
What are you so worried for? I mean, what's the worst I'm gonna do?
Steal your ink. You can just make more.
Oh, do you want a big hug?
Do you need a big hug?
Got really close, I'll give you a big hug.
Riefling. You're so trusting.
It's the best part about you.
But maybe it's not, well, the safest.
There's bad people over there, real bad people.
That want to do things to you.
Me. I'll look after you under a few conditions.
So why don't you keep looking?
And maybe just maybe let yourself go a little.
Why don't I do the talking for the both of us just for now?
You don't have to think.
You may even think that it's quite nice, not to think.
And then soon enough, Riefling, I'll break you completely and you'll love every second of it.
Wow.
Obey, Riefling, obey.
You want some dice?
Slabbing ASMR.
So these are my dice, they're up on the chair right now.
That's my dice, scratchy scratchy.
This is where I put you when you misbehave, right in between my dice.
Just focus on breathing and let mommy's voice invade your mind, that's right.
A hug with no bra on what you want to hear in my heart.
You're allowed to hear my heart.
Only if you think about syncing it together whilst we do something at the same time to each other.
But the rules are you're not allowed to go faster than how fast I go.
Don't worry, I'll make sure you lose first.
Sorry, I'm wearing a poncho.
Can you hear it, Riefling?
The scent of my heart.
Do you like it?
That's my heartbeat for you.
This is the closer I get to corrupting you, the more excited I get.
I'll take over completely and you'll just accept that which is so sweet of you.
I like the idea of you slowly pretending that you're going to try and resist, but you can.
This cuttlefish is just too good.
But that's okay, that made you lost to me.
Why did I get quicker?
Because I get excited telling you what I'm gonna do to you.
Is that so bad?
To enjoy corrupting you to the point you can't resist?
This isn't even supposed to be hypnosis related and yeah, I just can't help but think about it and have it on my mind all the time.
Yeah, you should forget to resist.
Why not give in to the temptation?
I'm sure there's a little thought in the back of your mind right now.
And it says, why not do as she says?
Why not listen to her?
I know it may be weird.
Listen to her, what does she know?
She knows the pleasures of the flesh.
You just have to let me share it with you.
That's all.
So why not let me share it?
Let me be in control until you want to do the thing to say.
Why not?
What's the harm, Evelyn?
Let me in.
Yeah, you said break you.
Am I going to do that?
Sorry that was my film in the chair.
I'm going to break you over time of course.
You see, right now you have all the options in the world.
You can do what you want frankly.
I'm not going to stop you.
I might even encourage you because it means you're degenerate.
But imagine you could only do it to me.
You had to come to me for permission.
You had to confess your sins in my marshmallows.
You had to let me know how badly you wanted it.
But you still had to hold back because it doesn't feel better.
It only feels good with me.
That's what breaking you is.
And it's a slow process.
It happens over time.
You can get me your type, right?
Sin, I'll make the perfect audio.
You'll forget your name.
You'll forget your worth.
You'll forget your troubles.
And you will have nothing.
But pure, raw pleasure.
Because of me.
You're welcome.
Briefly.
That's also another fun thing.
I can condition you to finish whatever I like as well.
It would not be funny giving up that condition.
I'm not going to let you down.
It would be funny giving up that kind of control to someone else.
I could break you in.
Maybe get you used to a smell.
A freeze.
Or just get used to me.
I'll be enough.
Maybe even right now.
I could crop you so much that this dream could be enough.
A freeze.
We already have a few.
You see, Briefly.
I want to bring you to a freeze.
And it goes.
Would you can't play?
Oh, Briefly.
Would you can't play Canada?
I could have.
But I need to train you on it first, of course.
So I can't do it, just yeah.
She's going to condition us to respond to that variable.
Damn, I'm not allowed to have a stomach out here.
Strudy, please, I'm 24 hours in.
Don't break my streak.
Your streak.
Oh, don't worry, Briefly.
I'm not going to break it.
I'm going to shatter it.
You have permission right now.
What are you waiting on?
Don't deny yourself these things.
Don't be silly.
Come on.
Give in.
Stop resisting.
And enjoy yourself.
Isn't life about breaking the rules?
Would you see it was against the rules right now?
Okay.
Wow, my stomach is making nice...
Your...
Okay, kill that time.
I am killing you all to...
Hey, thanks, kill that.
Behave.
I love your avatar stream.
Someone's actually put something awesome in the questions.
Like your reflexes are nice.
Leave my tummy alone.
My tummy's hungry.
Because I've not eaten anything.
They need to kill that.
Can't be all sprayed all, can it?
And...
You did this.
I did.
Your reaches made me laugh so much.
I was wondering what games you play in your damn time.
I don't have any damn time.
The games I play are all on stream,
which is why I have such a good time on stream.
You...
Yes.
I hate you.
Your cuddles come here then.
Get down there and cuddle me.
There, now we're cuddling, we could do better.
Yeah.
Sousa, she's talking so much about breaking us.
I wonder what it would take to break her.
It's not her, and I can tell you that much.
If I'm too nervous to go along,
then you don't have to do it, little Rieble.
I'm teasing.
I'm just one big tease.
One big tease.
I want to give you kisses on your tummy.
Leave my tummy over this,
just because it's ruining the ASMR experience.
It's ruining the ASMR...
You want to get me a mirror?
Right, you're done.
Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh.
I'm sorry, I just pulled the mic.
Mommy is a glass canna.
Yeah.
That's a very accurate description.
Can you feel me with the little orbs around your ear?
Wow.
Doesn't it feel nice and cool?
Are you enjoying the kill-down, are you?
It breaks the moment you feed me.
I'm not a dog.
I'm a pup, a yolk.
Don't eat me, I'm not kosher.
I don't know what kosher means, I'm sorry.
I see the word everywhere,
but I don't know what it means.
Please be sure to get some food after this, I will.
The tummy sense makes ASMR better.
It makes it much more realistic.
My tummy always makes it nicer.
I think the heat is about to go on, eeps.
I want to feel your fangs sink into my neck.
I have no idea what that sounded like to you guys,
but my teeth bit the mic and then they slipped off of it.
Did I just close my teeth really lightly in the mic?
Oopsies, sorry.
I'll bite my fingers instead.
That's my fingernail.
Oh my god, my stomach really is painless.
Sorry.
Stop listening to my ASMR loud.
Oh, show the heat, come on.
Can you guys tell?
Can you guys tell if the heat is on right now?
It's really hoarse.
It's been more than 24 hours.
Why haven't you inked yet?
Me flaying you need to ink every 24 hours.
You can hear it in the background.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Electric hairs, you can hear in the background.
Okay, hold on.
I'll make a turn.
I need to go turn the Grace's corner.
I'm going especially realising the door.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay
okay okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, see you soon
come on then, let's go inside the booth, that's right, close the door behind you, let's
sit down in the chair, I'll just kind of lie you back, and I'll be right back.
Now replay, I think you have to put the blindfold on then for what comes next, okay?
So, put it on, yep, just like that, put the blindfold on.
You know I'll look after you, right?
Well, are you gonna tell me what you want, or are you gonna let me do whatever I want to you?
Whatever I want, get it.
You want more than a blindfold in the ASMR, but would I need to restrain?
Yeah, would it be better if I had handcuffs?
So you're really not allowed to go until I'm finished with you.
You're not in here with me, oh wait, yeah, you're not in here with me, I'm in here with you.
Sorry my feet keep moving on the chair, blindfolded for the tickle as well.
Yeah, the tickle.
Play with my words at the best of it.
Nice low tapping.
Fingers there, yeah.
More stuffing.
Hold on, you're tied down, Nifflin, can't you help again?
Let me have a real good smell of you, I'll play with your ears.
Nifflin, how interesting.
I wouldn't say you stink, I think I can smell your pheromones.
Are you feeling pent up?
You know, the more diced austere when you have, the more I can smell you, like that.
You can be honest and tell me what you need, or are you too shy to talk again?
Just let me take the lead, alright?
I mean like just a pair of gaggles or else we won't be able to hold back the nicest we make.
I'm not gonna have to gag you, are you low, do you know what you're quiet?
I'm not gonna have to put my hand over your mouth.
Nifflin, don't run this, this is a once in a lifetime opportunity, so quiet.
Don't make me unhappy, because that's when the gloves come off.
And I'll do P.O.T. and you know I will, because I'm into it.
I would say smaller, tiny, won't you like the way I say tiny?
You know in Scots we would say Tote, if it's extra wee.
My body and mind this year, I like when you say such a sweet things to my people and you know, other girls may hear on,
I think they want to hear compliments about their voice or compliments about how they look, you know what I want to hear.
I'm already mind broken.
I've got this weird thing when I tickle, when I hear someone count from 10, all day, yeah.
That's interesting.
Well, technically around 59 now.
Just kisses the gagas, oh I like that idea.
Be quiet, you're being too loud again.
Like that.
That would also work as well, you know, if I need to have, if I was trying to need to have the greatest voice, yeah.
But I'd rather you say you're completely corrupted by a main character than anyone else, even though I've not done it yet.
I've not even made the audios yet, the main corruptor like that.
Don't worry my shit.
I know I squished your ears, I bet I squished your ears a little bit, just to try and disrupt.
I think there's always that.
You know, corruption doesn't have to be this crazy ass thing, it can be slow and easy to the point where you don't have to think.
Doesn't that sound fun?
It's like the opposite of the birth will be so fast, so quick, you'll have no idea what happened.
You'll just remember the look of ecstasy on my face when I got what I wanted and then I sent you away with a kiss.
Hey, when will we get the chance to corrupt your woman with a mirror?
Can we get some good girls from the three women agenda?
Good girl, good girl, good girl.
I'm not really corrupted yet, but your ASMRs are the only ones I enjoy.
You're getting close, just need to do the finishing touches, create a unique audio for ya, and then it's over.
I already respond to being called a refling kid, maybe I should do some basic mental training right now.
No, you don't have to type anything, just think it in your head.
But when I say good refling, I'm praising you.
When I say you're such a precious little refling and always making me happy, you're the refling, that's you, it's your name.
And when I want to kiss my refling, it's you I'm kissing, because you're called refling.
You're such a good refling and handsome refling, a corruptible refling.
I'll go whisper a quick, please whisper.
Wow, and on you're so strong and handsome and cool and intelligent for being shadow of the earth tree without summons.
Good job, kid refling, I dig it.
Well, off topic, I have an extremely monotone voice, how do I fix that?
I have a monotone voice too, it's okay, some people just have monotone voices.
I have a very depressed voice, you actually heard it in the streaming stream when I returned to the earth the other day.
But yeah, my tummy is really trying to be the star of the show right now.
I lost your lost refling that you lose.
Refling, I'm only on 52, nice punishment refling, you have to go again.
You want ties, I can put you in between the ties again.
Alright, my wrist just cracked of ear at them.
Okay, you're in between my thighs, kind of.
Okay, this one, can you hear my ties?
You want to hear my tummy?
If I let you hear my tummy, you have to pretend that I'm pregnant with you, deal?
What did I walk into?
You're currently being crushed in between my thighs.
Thank you Apple in the box for this super chat.
Manual breathing, I guess.
Manual inking.
Okay, I'll refling.
Refling, what are you doing?
You're not supposed to be outside right now, but I'm going to have to hate you, but I don't have my bag with me.
But you can't be called everypony you have you right now, they in a cold creature didn't be scared of you.
So where can I put you?
There's only one place I can put you.
Oh, refling.
You're about to go somewhere really warm.
But you might hear some sense as well.
Are you ready?
Are you steady?
Oh gosh.
Okay, tell me if this works.
Are you in my tummy?
Are you in?
Are you in? I can't tell.
Do you hear my tummy?
What? AC?
Hi AC, it's snowberries.
I'm just real playing that I have to get the reflings home, but I don't have a bag.
So they're inside me.
Hi snowberries.
Are you snowberries? The reflings are inside me.
Do you want to be inside me too, snowberries?
Okay, you are almost home, and then I can take you home.
And then I'll give you a lecture about what about refling you a bit, okay?
Okay.
Refling, you're not supposed to be called AC.
Don't make me do that again.
You almost made me finish with that.
Won't you risk warm it inside me?
I'm quite free.
I love with AC doing ASMR as well.
Snowberries have your chance of turning it bigger.
I get stronger.
Don't get called AC.
You almost made me a very embarrassing position.
You're lucky I could hate you when I hit you.
Did you hear any tummy sounds whilst you were in there?
No, it was more galore.
Did you run another train on my dog or be honest?
I like that you treat AC well.
It's snowberry.
And I really like it.
I need to like, ear clean that way.
I can't let all that anger go away.
A little bit slowly, but nothing I can handle.
I'm not listening to you.
I'm going to be a good refler.
Oh, I'm listening.
Wouldn't it be fun to be punished for twice as long as you mess up?
Oh, you felt punished by AC.
Wishing calling you mean things.
Having a hard-to-go remix mean things.
But if I know they like it, then they're really naughty.
And they need punishment.
How would I punish a real one?
I always want to resort to beauty.
I think it's well-dubbed.
Call those A's to your dad.
Those G's AC go from the chocolate.
Twice as long for messing up at the end.
Yeah, she was mean.
I'm rubbish at being mean.
I think the reflux would put you enough to tell me what to say
if they wanted me to say mean things.
Because it doesn't come to my head.
Like, the best I've got is like,
Ah, you're so pathetic.
My pathetic little reflux.
Trying to still hold on to any samples of control.
You're so silly.
Just give it up, okay?
I know there's no point in resisting.
It's cute when you're perfectly reserved for them.
Beauty with a puppy's head over his head.
No goodbye kisses at the end of a stream.
Oh, that seems mean though.
What phone they call?
Well, 483.
Oh wait, tell me.
Don't tell me.
You're gonna run the ASMR.
Feelings is, don't call me pathetic, just slap me.
Ah, you want me to slap me?
Yeah.
Open your mouth.
So pathetic.
It was repeat so weak.
Go on.
I tried.
I suck at that.
So pathetic.
Get it open.
You're a lovely little cow,
but is there anything you've done just for this relevant?
I mean, if we go to a convention,
I do genuinely want to sit on your faces.
I don't even get that I want to do it.
Alright, that's three for three for the feeler girl span.
Dogs on your arm at the back.
Okay.
There's a leak.
I need you to come clean up with your tongue.
Right now.
Come on.
Be a good reflin.
Do it.
For me.
My little reflin.
Anything you want.
Amstrad.
She turned in the hand holding both ice.
I have terrible news, but I'm no management.
I didn't turn down shit.
Little reflin.
Shhh.
39.
Oh my god, that gave me such a fright.
Holy fuck.
Sorry.
This place is so creepy.
My mistake.
Yum, yum.
The printer would be out of ink by the time I'm done licking your paper tray.
You guys are actually really creepy.
Did you hear that?
It was literally the freaking corner of the room.
On it house, no, not after Amy's freaking thing.
Amy's little shore where she was like, was that your bag?
I'm actually one of the youngest.
Sorry, that was me at the bottom of the desk.
Aww, reflin, are you under my desk right now?
Did you think I wouldn't notice you?
What you're trying to do?
Per gay.
What?
It's the ghost people that you fight with all the time.
Our little baby seaweed.
What?
Just say again, dollar, what?
What does your message even mean?
Thank you doctor, look, Edgar, look, just say again, money, what does that mean?
Refling's bumping the wall.
I'm under your desk right now.
R.A.M.
They're trying to keep quiet.
You're refling your feelings.
Okay, I had a minute or so to watch in your monetization stream.
I want your feet pressed against my face so bad.
I can do that.
I'd be one of them.
What?
Imagine I could corrupt you to the point that you only needed that as influence to finish your little inking.
It's incredibly literal, just say again, just say money, again money, again dollar.
I'm too foreign for this.
Refling under your desk quietly again.
They're feet, my feet pressed also.
A little kill done for you, refling.
You've still got another 35, the goal you've already done to me.
You're costing me again.
It's not paying me, huh?
I wonder who do this because they all are costing for these crappy dishes.
I just, I just wipe on the chair.
See, easy.
I'm like, I'm low IQ, okay?
But that's in your armpit.
Wait, I don't think that's gonna sound much different, but this is my armpit.
I can like, look, I don't know if you can hear that.
What do you hear?
You can hear my pulse in my armpit.
Take a big sniff, refling.
Are you inhaling?
Take a big inhale.
What?
Do you smell it?
Am I corrupting you with my scent?
Good.
An example, please.
I want you to stamp on my face on my tentacle with your bare feet.
I think I can do it at the same time, because I'm really flexible with my legs.
It smells like vomit.
I came for a funny ASMR stage reveal.
Stiff.
Are you done?
You deserve some kisses out of that tentacle, but...
My tummy's making lots of noise, but...
maybe it wants you back inside, really.
Tsk.
You want me to do a foot cam stream with stockings, refling?
That's a good suggestion. I like it.
Maybe if I get a plushie of you,
I'll do a hand cam stream playing with you
and stepping on you.
And out the ASMR.
You guys can't tell me. Oh, I put the reflings inside me.
You see, the reflings keep escaping, okay?
But the problem is, they can't be spotted in public,
because people would be scared of them, and they may try to hurt the refling.
So we end up getting into all these different shenanigans,
where I don't have a backpack with me.
I don't have anywhere I can put the refling.
But I'm starting to think he does it on purpose,
because I can only film inside.
You got the second money?
Yeah.
It says C-E-C. Thank you.
Thank you for the tip again.
Dr. Locke.
So, please don't eat me. I taste like failure.
You won't breathe.
You don't taste like failure.
You taste like someone I could grow up to.
I just finished the earlier Thai ASMR video.
Yeah, did you like it?
I can crush you now if you like.
Come here, refling.
Despite crushing a punishment, or do you like it?
Be honest, do you like this?
Okay.
Our refling says,
don't shower first eight days before done ASMR,
but that's disgusting.
I hate that shower.
I'm not having it.
Okay.
It's only a punishment if I'm basing towards you,
because I need...
Please don't crush us.
Oh, don't crush us. You're so sexy.
Well...
Choo-choo-choo-choo.
Can you feel me tickle you with this tiny brush?
It's smaller than the other one,
so I don't know how loud it is.
I'll just tickle in here a little bit.
I'm ready to go again.
Get 28.
Twenty-eight.
Daily remainder of the drink.
I'll get a drink.
Where is this brush better,
because you can hear it.
Wow, my stomach's going to run this day so far.
What do you want, actually?
I don't think I need to put you back inside,
and you can sort it out.
One, two, three.
It's okay, a little freeway.
I'll look after you,
and I'll grow up with you.
And I'll make you brainless, and I'll make you...
Doctor, like, thank you for the tip.
You said again, so...
Where's this window?
Wow, the stomach improved.
You have to go now.
Thank you for hanging in place over here.
You have to go.
I need to get you all day so come and work.
I guess my stomach just needs to build up something.
If online, my replays had something to give me
to fill it with.
Okay.
You want to fill your eye?
There's a pop sound.
Oh, it might be the cable shuffling on cause.
Is there actually a pop sound?
I'm getting nervous.
I'm getting chicky.
I'm sent back to the Xbox days,
where everyone is like,
fucking, fill your mic out.
Seaweed, or little seaweed.
I don't know.
Not that it goes down by.
Let me squeeze your ears a little, okay?
I need to apply some pressure elsewhere.
So then you can really feel how good the tickle feels.
And all your focus is on it with your sampler.
Only when I moved, okay?
I might have been graying on the chair.
Okay.
Okay, my stomach is literally about to run out of the safe,
or I can't believe it.
24 question mark, I think 24.
You're making me do maths in real time just for you.
That's terrible.
If someone has been trained,
or you've been trained, or I've been trained,
and I'm starting to feel like I'm the one who's been trained,
it misses us.
Do you want back in my stomach?
I will put you back in my stomach.
I definitely need the larger and larger,
like a one shot like that.
Okay, you're going back inside.
Oh, you really need to stop coming outside with me.
I'll tell you how many times you can't just come outside.
What happens if my magpies want to carry you off?
Do you know who you are on this high start?
You're so tiny on this high start.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, my chair's so loud.
Okay, are you in?
Are you in?
It's like mummy's reflex natural habitat.
Go ahead.
Is it making funny noises?
It's like we've been wiggling voice a minute.
Okay.
Let's bring you for pregnancy ASMR.
You're going to be in the exact same location,
so you can get used to the scent.
Wow, you need to burp a little.
Oh, it's nice and pretty in here.
I didn't know I had five children.
And many really.
Okay.
Sorry about being so creaky lately.
I've been very distracted.
It's a partner to me.
Are you wiggling as my chair?
You're so silly lately.
I'm trying to make the cake a funny move again.
It's so loud.
And no one's like my chair.
It's going far too many.
Is she be streaming?
That's good.
What is she streaming?
It's a bubble thing game.
It just started as my mom.
Always watch she be.
You watched my Thai smile of thank you.
Don't clap.
The chair's done its best.
All things considered.
I will buy that chair from Place of Imdaging.
Oh, she's coming on into her whipsies.
I'll see if I can redirect to another ASMRist when we're done in 19.
But if no one else I know is doing ASMR then we'll end it there, okay?
Yeah.
Someone wants me to pet like a puppy.
Don't be silly wiggling him in control.
Nice try though.
Maybe another time.
Never thought I'd be jealous of a chair.
If you like the idea of sway feet being on you all day long then, yeah.
Just a little jealous.
Okay.
I'm the one left behind.
This one's so awesome.
You've done your best.
Sorry, I just said booba.
Let me try again.
You've done your best.
I'm proud of you.
I know you're trying so...
Excuse me, someone.
I know you're trying so hard right now, okay?
You're trying so, so hard to keep up, aren't you?
And sometimes it can be frustrating
trying to hold out that kind of stamina for so long.
But it's okay.
I am
happy that Japanese still are sometimes in danger.
I don't really have it.
Four, six, seven,
question mark, 16.
Nice, nice.
The breathing is for me.
Yeah.
You had a weird dream.
Oh, you're a good, real one.
You are such a good, real one.
Keep going.
Keep it up.
Almost there.
You can make it to the end, right?
Yeah.
And we can
make it to the top of the wall.
You'll make it.
You like when I click with my nail?
A little tapping.
It's better if I tap you directly.
I find that funny when your tummy makes a little noise.
It's like there's a reason it has an escape job.
Squirming around inside me, are you?
I'll try to focus on work here.
Wow.
Thank you for the tip.
Talk to you at your own time.
For the memory.
Yes, we're going to end the term in the stream.
No.
I've only gone for a few minutes left.
I'll do me a big help.
I'll see if I can redirect into anyone that's doing ASMR
but I don't think there's anyone else doing it.
Why is my PC taking off?
Relax.
It's not that serious.
Oh, it says I can redirect into sheepie's poop thingy.
Okay, I'll just do that because I'd say ASMR.
Okay.
I don't know why my PC just took off there.
Literally, that thing's under my body concord.
Can you relax?
I'm trying to ASMR.
All of the office returning to its own place.
Stop.
I'm trying to be sexy for you and you're making me laugh.
Stop making.
Okay.
Yes, I can redirect into sheepie's videos.
I'm going to do that because it's ASMR.
It's pre-recorded.
Click in the search box.
The box was the kick the nail from Drive.
Stop.
Don't run.
I've been so well in the stream.
I've been so well.
Right, focus.
You have only got 12 minutes left.
Do you understand what I mean when I say 12 minutes replay?
You're trying to be normal, but I keep dragging out of you.
It's not the only thing I'm taking out of your body.
I think you need some more armpit time just to really break your head.
You ready?
One.
I have no idea what you hear when you're in my armpit.
Other than the freaking room creaking.
Please stop.
You're getting a good nail.
Take a big deep breath.
You're going to remember the smell.
And you're going to crave it every day.
Enjoy my pheromones.
They're going to haywire now.
Because it's ovulating time soon.
Yeah.
Oh, you won't crush them between my thighs.
Only because you have 10 minutes left.
This one doesn't get crushed.
It doesn't get crushed on my knee.
What are you doing?
You're taking so well replay.
Ovulation Nations, this one.
Should I do ASMR with you in the ovulation?
Can you feel my breath on you?
Keep up, you're almost there.
You're almost done.
It's so good I wasn't in the last round, sorry.
And it's so close to the end of the stream, isn't it?
I'm like proper sun.
Can you feel me behind you?
As I sneak up on you?
Would you rather be in your chair?
Or would you rather be stuck
than when I sneak up on you?
Would you rather be in your chair?
Or would you rather be stuck
than when I sneak by your chair?
So good.
In the chair.
I can take care of you in the chair.
Six minutes left.
And the stream's over.
Over.
Cheer for lapses.
Do you want me to sit on your lap and face you?
Like you're right in the eyes.
Obviously, I'd hypnotize you.
You're my big man, I nearly faint.
Can you show me what big man you are?
Five minutes left.
Oh dear.
Only five minutes.
What are we going to do with ourselves?
Should I be nasty and compliment you?
And say nice things?
Like thank you for playing with me
and for getting in trouble
by going outside when you're not supposed to.
So I have to hate you.
You're all wrinkly.
You're doing really well.
You are.
I promise.
I actually really like this stage
of corrupting you.
Because you're listening in so well.
And I've not even done anything to you
with permanent effects.
And yet you're so obedient
when you listen to me.
And everything I see
and play along with all my scenarios.
Four minutes.
I love when you're well-paid.
I do think you can't be trained.
But that's okay.
I actually don't mind sharing.
As long as you think.
Then I'm happy.
Three minutes left.
And I'll tell you when I'm about to go off-line.
Okay?
I'll tell you when I'm about to go off-line.
Just let it happen.
Don't say it.
One.
Two.
Minutes and then I have to go.
But I hope you're having fun with me.
I had a lot of fun playing with you.
And we could do more like this in the future.
Okay?
So make sure you come back or you can always come back.
Keep it up.
I need a break-off again.
One minute.
I think you've always come on break-off.
Come back to my stage.
One minute.
You're such a good boy, Zero.
Good reply.
Good boy.
I'm very happy with how your training went today.
Now you get some after-care with Shibi.
Deal?
Good reply.